Jenna's been filling in for the last
month and she's been awesome and
extraordinary and she fits I mean it's
like we're like one big family and I
think we all feel that it would mean
it'd be great I feel like I got the best
job I get to sit next to these
incredible human I get to travel the
world and meet incredible people who are
doing extraordinary things and so we'll
see I mean I don't think we'll see Jenna
Bush Hager and Hoda Kotb hinting that
Jenna could be Kathie Lee Gifford's
permanent Today Show replacement we're
gonna be friends for the rest of our
lives and I just I'm grateful to God for
you
Kathie Lee is leaving the show after 11
years and her co-hosts tele T they're
planning a major send-off you've heard
of the Queen's Jubilee okay
multiply that by about 10 and that's
gonna be Kathie Lee send off we are
planning like an epic send-off I mean
it's bittersweet obviously because I
mean she has been such a part of my life
for sure and the show's life but Kath is
ready like you can see it in her eye I
don't think I've ever seen her this
happy but we're gonna have tons of
surprises she's not gonna know what hit
her but it's gonna be an extravaganza
she's not leaving till April so we have
months and months and months to
celebrate her and she deserves nothing
less
eg caught up with the ladies of today at
a luncheon for the Hudson River Park
friends playground committee in New York
City we all have little kids and this is
our backyard now which is different than
how any of us grew up but
so important that our kids get outside
and play and so the Hudson River Park
was a pretty cool place to do it I think
when it turned spring in New York it is
a magical time my daughter actually had
an incident where she popped a squat in
the park so that was a memory I don't
know if it was a favorite it was
probably a least favorite I never
imagined that I would be here at an
event like this talking about my
daughter going to the park but it
happens and then if she has her one
place to go it's any swing anywhere at
any time
yeah it's so fun we all have kids in the
same age range almost all of all of us
and so it's really fun to have
colleagues to get you in multiple ways
and I feel like we have that effect
today she would please say to say it's
like a family but I can ask them advice
we've been talking a lot about sleeping
yeah but I can also ask them about work
and like what a cool and what a cool
place to work